[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le sky
échos votre magazine qui vous racontent
la vie des acteurs économiques sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et pour ce magazine nous sommes au siège
de gennari ce groupe à guyancourt
cette entité d composé de douze
entreprises & start up spécialisée dans
l'innovation et vous le verrez son
bâtiment est adapté aux nouvelles
méthodes et organisation du travail
mais avant cela voici le sommaire du
deuxième numéro du sky échos
la crise sanitaire a eu des conséquences
sur l'immobilier d'entreprise entre le
télétravail et nouvelle organisation de
l'espace une réflexion s'engage enfin
présentation d'une collaboration entre
deux entreprises du territoire le
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines où un partenariat avec sky one
portal une start up spécialisée dans la
réalité virtuelle
[Musique]
je vous en parlais au début de ce
magazine le groupe gennari s'est
installé dans son nouveau siège à
guyancourt un site de 5000 m² sur
plusieurs étages et pour en parler nous
sommes avec gérard dalle son président
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi consiste ce nouveau
site c'est un site colonna voulu avec
fixé quatre objectifs inspirant parce
que nous sommes dans le cadre de
l'innovation technologique la capacité
donc de prendre en compte les
technologies d'aujourd'hui et de demain
qu créatif pin évidemment puisque donc
nous travaillons dans un cluster avec
différentes entités et puis corps king
pas ce qui est bien évidemment on va
accueillir on cherche à accueillir des
porteurs de projets capables donc de
d'être de pouvoir donc s'inscrire dans
notre écosystème de développement je le
rappelle generix group ces deux entités
un vous venez de le dire engagés dans
l'innovation technologique
tout à fait comment vous avez pensé ces
différents espaces et quels différents
espaces retrouve tombe sur ce site alors
on a on a voulu effectivement donc
réfléchir au cas d'usagé
on a donc voir de quelle manière on
pouvait imaginer le travail
d'aujourd'hui le travail de demain la
capacité des équipes à travailler je
suis en poste de travail mais aussi
travailler en commun pouvoir échanger
donc il y a donc des zones pour lequel
on peut travailler on peut discuter
on peut téléphoner donc voilà donc avec
des espaces collaboratifs comme suit ici
une petite salle donc avec donc un
espace qui permet d'un peu chaleureux
donc capable dé changer très rapidement
sur un projet
d'autres espaces beaucoup plus confiné
défaut de boxe pour s'isoler pour toi
pour éventuellement donc échangé avec
soin sur appels privés mais aussi un
appel professionnel dans lequel on veut
un espace donc voilà donc on a cherché
avec les équipes du groupe avec le
cluster s'est fait plaisir s'est lâché
pour faire un soin qu'on ait ces c'est
tous ces espaces là donc donc vous voyez
l'exemple aujourd'hui la ici c'est un
bâtiment intelligent aussi au niveau
énergétique mais aussi au niveau de
petits outils qui font peut-être qu'ils
changent le quotidien voilà c'est ça oui
tout à fait on est on a imaginé des
solutions avec un immeuble sans serrure
avec que des serrures et
l'unique différence électronique bien
évidemment je crois qu'on en a quatre
quatre modèles de cérémonie pour essayer
donc de traiter différents usages
notamment usage des toilettes avec la
capacité de passer sa main sans contact
et pouvoir aller aux toilettes donc sans
aucun problème donc là on était avant le
quoran amyris ont été capables
d'imaginer donc des solutions qui est
vite propagé olivier alors justement
vous vous en parle et finalement on a
l'impression que vous êtes en avance
vous avez déjà anticipé disons les cas
d' usage de peut-être de l'immobilier
d'entreprise du futur oui tout à fait
parce que dans le cluster nous avons
différentes entités et notre rôle c'est
effectivement de réfléchir aux usages de
demain donc on parle de cas d' usage
ça c'est un travail c'était une
recherche c'est un certain ces issues de
différentes réunions est en train et on
essaie d'imaginer des solutions pour les
différents opérateurs différents
collaborateurs mais aussi des personnes
extérieures donc on a voulu donc que ce
soit l'expression même de nos réflexions
qu'ils soient mineurs
merci géré à bâle merci beaucoup
président de generix group
[Musique]
un rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
le mercredi 14 octobre saint quentin en
yvelines organise la matinale des
acteurs de l'immobilier c'est au domaine
de grand'maisons à villepreux
il sera question de l'évolution de
l'immobilier d'entreprise après la crise
sanitaire
et justement nous avons fait le bilan du
marché sur saint quentin en yvelines
avec christine de beauregard directrice
attractivité et immobilier d'entreprise
à l'agglomération
[Musique]
l'immobilier d'entreprise c'est 4
millions 1,6 mètre carré de d'immobilier
d'entreprise tous confondus
[Musique]
nous notre rôle c'est d'accompagner les
porteurs de projets à trouver des soies
des terrains disponibles soit des
bâtiments pour pour pouvoir implanter
leurs activités
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle nous avons environ
entre 250000 et 300 mille mètres carrés
en cours de développement
quand on dit en cours de développement
ce sont des projets sur lesquels on
travaille avec les opérateurs en 2019 on
a fait une année vraiment très
intéressant pas aussi bonne que celle de
2018 mais très très intéressante avec
avec des grands comptes qui ont qui ont
bougé
[Musique]
les entreprises réfléchissent beaucoup à
la suite qu'ovide à la suite télétravail
le télétravail
s'il continue de se développer les
entreprises ont libéré des mètres carrés
va falloir les animer il va falloir
créer de nouvelles surfaces créer de
nouveaux usages faire des espaces de
coworking faire des espaces d'animation
pour que les salariés puissent se
rencontrer pour que les équipes projets
puissent se rencontrer également
[Musique]
dans business kyle le partenariat entre
le théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines et la start-up sky one portal
cette société spécialisée dans la
réalité virtuelle va expérimenter une
technologie à partir de la captation
d'un spectacle pour le théâtre national
c'est la possibilité de développer
l'accessibilité à la culture pour le
public
regardez
[Musique]
c'est une collaboration d'abord
territoriale puisque nous ça nous
intéresse c'est d'être dans une
connexion avec les entreprises du
territoire essentiellement d'ailleurs
avec les jeunes entreprises comme c'est
le cas de sky one
on travaille sur des solutions
exploitant la technologie immersive donc
réalité virtuelle augmentée
on apporte son savoir-faire dans le
déploiement des usages immersif pour
effectivement abordé la problématique du
spectacle vivant qui doit être
accessible dans des endroits aujourd'hui
en dehors du terrain
[Musique]
on accueille dans quelques jours une
création c'est-à-dire une première d'un
spectacle d'une chanteuse qui s'appelle
rose marie stanley sur scène elle sera
dans la salle juste à côté de la salle à
un endroit que l'on décidera ça peut
être à côté de la salle ça peut être à
15 kilomètres ça peut être à 100 km des
personnes qui n'ont pas la possibilité
de se déplacer puisse assister à ce
spectacle dans des conditions quasi
réelles
on va mettre en place en premier lieu
quelque chose assez classique avec une
diffusion du spectacle en 360°
stéréoscopique avec lunettes 3d et le
deuxième élément qu'on va mettre en
oeuvre ça va être la téléprésence où
cette technologie qu'on est en train de
finaliser qui la permettent en fait à
l'artiste de communiquer en hologramme
avec les personnes qui sont en dehors du
site
[Musique]
une des raisons d'être d'un théâtre et
de la scène national de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est véritablement de rendre
le spectacle l'art les arts vivants
accessible à tous en premier lieu
effectivement de valider la technologie
les scènes nationales sont intéressés
justement pour offrir le spectacle
déployer le plus possible notre deuxième
enjeu aussi c'est avec la suite
le déploiement de cette technologie on
veut si la mine autorisé et on va très
probablement début d'année prochaine
commencez à prototyper tout ça pour
avoir une solution vraiment portable en
haut avec un smartphone une paire de
lunettes on commencera à pouvoir faire
on va dire le zoom ou le skype immersif
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et mission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]
m